bonjour Daniel Rolo bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous publiez ko Football Club
chez Hugo sport édition un livre dans
lequel vous revenez sur les les
différentes affaires qui ont Tillé le le
football français ces derniers mois avec
ce ton direct et sans langue de bois que
l'on vous connaît entourage des joueurs
dirigeants Neymar veratti tout le monde
en prend un peu pour son gr dans dans ce
livre déjà votre titre Daniel Riolo le
ton est donné Koo Football Club pourquoi
ce titre alors il faut savoir qu'au
début c'est pas le titre qu'on voulait
donner parce que le le sujet initial qui
découlait de mes précédentes études ou
recherches ou j'aimais bien m'intéresser
à l'entourage des joueurs
euh on était plutôt en train de se
diriger justement et spécifiquement sur
ce qui entourait les joueurs il y avait
eu différentes affaires qui circulaient
depuis pas mal de temps autour de
joueurs de plus en plus sollicités par
des entourages malveillants et deux
trois affaires de raquette euh dont une
qui qui traînait dont on entendait
parler sans arrêt sans avoir réellement
de preuve euh autour deolo Kanté joueur
aimé par toute la France euh au moment
de la Coupe du Monde 2018 et euh le
contraste saisissant entre son profil de
de de bon élève de de gentil garçon
qu'il est d'ailleurs et un entourage qui
a fini par le gangrainer au point où il
est parti en Angleterre avec euh surtout
l'envie de ne jamais revenir en France
pour ne plus être confronté à ces à ses
faux amis ça c'était un peu l'idée de
départ derrière sont arrivé d'autres
affaires vous l'avez un peu évoqué dans
la présentation tout à l'heure
évidemment qu'au moment où on se lance
dans le livre et quiexlose cette affaire
Pogba on se dit ah bah voilà là on
touche du doigt tout ce qu'on nous a
raconté depuis longtemps et qu'il était
difficile de prouver ben là on a face
caméra le frère d'un joueur emblématique
de l'équipe de France et on est en
pleine affaire de de raquett et de
joueurs soumis à des entourages dont il
n'arrive pas à à à se défaire et le
titre devait être ghetto Football
Club sauf que une fois qu'on s'est lancé
dans dans les premières recherches et
qu'on a évoqué l'entourage s'est dit ce
serait quand même dommage de ne rester
focalisé que sur ces entourages là sans
essayer de comprendre pourquoi euh
certaines personnes se disent que ce
gâteau est absolument énorme et que tout
le monde veut croquer des pars de ce
gâteau est-ce qu'il faut pas voir s'il y
aurait pas euh au-dessus euh du terrain
et des joueurs euh des gens responsables
de cette situation et là on parle des
clubs des dirigeants de club des agents
également des agents et de la
concurrence entre les agents les ce
qu'on appelle les anciens agents et les
nouveaux agents et évidemment euh
derrière tout ça la Fédération Française
de Football puisque au même moment en
tout cas euh en septembre de l'année
dernière éclatait euh l'affaire autour
de la 3F et les soucis pour Noël lerette
qui ont conduit un dit sur la situation
et la gestion de la de la Fédération
Française de Football et petit à petit à
la prise de position politique de la
ministre des sport et au bout du compte
au départ de Noël ler on va revenir sur
sur tous ces tous ces sujets que vous
avez évoqué commençons d'abord par le le
parisint-germain on a vu ces images
Messi Neymar veratti qui ont quitté le
club l'été dernier pour des destinations
exotiques les États-Unis pour Messi
l'Arabie Saoudite pour Neymar le Qatar
pour le Qatar pour verati en voyant ces
images vous m'avez dit tiens voilà les
escrots pourquoi les
escrot c'est pas tant eux parce que eux
eux après tout n'y sont pour rien eux
ils profitent d'une situation de club en
l'occurrence le parissaingermain qui a
envie de faire de la pub avec eux de de
de les payer de façon totalement
démesuré eux après tout ils sont l'objet
d'un énorme système ils en profitent
mais si après tout un joueur absolument
fabuleux qui pour les amateurs de foot
est une idole et pour moi aussi s'il
vient au PSG qu'il a pas envie d'y être
qu'il se traîne sur le terrain quand il
y est qui prend un salaire de fou qu' ne
daigne jamais saluer les supporters qui
part alors qu'entreetemps il gagne quand
même la Coupe du monde avec l'Argentine
en étant exemplaire et en étant une
idole absolu pour tout un pays justere
oui bien sûr il s'est servi du
pariss-germain donc en fait il prend les
gens pour des gogos mais encore une fois
c'est pas forcément lui le responsable
c'est ceux qui ont cru que c'était une
bonne idée de le recruter et il part aux
États-Unis là pour le coup dans une
démarche totalement business ou mais
encore une fois lui en profite mais la
MLS en profite parce que la major ligue
us a envie de faire sa promo autour de
ce joueur et c'est c'est pas lui
l'escroc l'escroquerie elle est complète
parce que le gars neous fait que quatre
matchs quatre matchs contre des pentins
des joueurs qui le laissent un petit peu
briller encore pour un dernier tour de
piste des matchs au cours desquels il
brille oui mais c'est un dernier tour de
piste qui sont ses adversaires qui sont
ses équipes on a l'impression que c'est
comme je vous disais c'est c'est c'est
c'est le vieux coner qui termine sur un
Costa Croisière avec son dernier tour de
champ bon voilà il ne fait que quatre
matchs et la MAJ la la la MLS veut lui
donner le titre de joueur de l'année
c'est évidemment que c'est une
escroquerie c'est de la pube c'est du
marketing c'est tout ce que c'est tout
ce que vous voulez mais c'est pas du
foot on parle pas de foot la même chose
pour Neymar Neymar il est très heureux
de trouver un dernier contrat en Arabie
Saoudite l'Arabie Saoudite veut
développer son football donc casse tout
sur le marché des transferts l'été
dernier recrute Neymar bon c'est une
veine pour le PSG parce qu'ils arrivent
pas à s'en débarrasser l'Arabie Saoudite
paye 90 millions pour un joueur qui
n'arrive même plus à dribler des
adversaire dans la Ligue des Champions
asiatiques voilà c'était des joueurs
finis on continue de nous dire que c'est
des grands joueurs c'est c'est c'est
pour ça que je disais que c'est c'était
une escroquerie eux au bout du compte
bon ils ne sont qu'un rouage de cet
énorme système le truc c'est que nous il
faut pas qu'on soit dupe de ça nous il
faut qu'on dise la vérité il faut qu'on
dise très bêtement qu'ils sont encore
les bons joueurs et qu' sont pas les
bons joueurs et pourquoi ils vont dans
les clubs c'est nous il faut qu'on
décrypte tous ces mécanismes là qui font
que un gamin de 20 ans un gamin de 15
ans qui s'intéresse au foot ah ah lui
c'est un super j non non non lui il est
là pour telle et telle raison lui il
faut pas faut pas qu'on se fasse enfler
en fait sur Neymar vous écrivez
notamment le plus grand le plus grand
effort du joueur de la C Sao éviteer les
boîte parisienne telle que le Matignon
où Marco veratti a longtemps fait partie
des meubles il faut dire que Neymar a
fait construire sa propre discothèque
privée de 150 m² chez lui les bus
remplis de filles débarquent
régulièrement et les téléphones
portables sont interdits est-ce que ça
c'est une tendance de fond qui concerne
beaucoup de joueurs le fait et bien de
ne plus s'intéresser à ce qui se passe
en bois de nuit que sur le terrain
est-ce que c'est vraiment représentatif
c'est c'est un vaste sujet qui en tout
cas dans dans l'aterfot nous nous
intéresse de plus en plus et euh sais il
y a récemment j'ai lu une interview de
Miroslav closeux ex international
allemand qui doit être encore maintenant
le recordman desb en Coupe du monde donc
une référence même s'il est peut-être
pas très populaire en France mais il
disait que la la nouvelle génération la
la question était peut-être de savoir si
ils étaient passionnés par ce qu'il
faisaient vous faites votre métier
j'imagine que vous êtes pas passionné
par ce que vous faites moi aussi je suis
passionné par ce que je fais euh on est
peut-être aussi passionné par ce qu'on
fait parce que parce qu'on voulait le
faire depuis qu'on est gamin et puis
parce que c'est c'est un métier qui se
rapproche de de la passion qu'on avait
pour l'information moi pour le foot eux
a prioris ils ont démarré c'est un rêve
d'être joueur de foot tous les gamins
qui qui jouent à 6 7 ans 8 ans ont envie
de devenir joueur professionnel après il
y a ceux qui peuvent et ceux qui peuvent
pas et c'est très dur de devenir pro
ont-ils ensuite une fois qu'il signne le
premier contrat pro euh toujours cette
passion où est-ce que euh euh la gloire
euh l'argent qui leur tombe dessus euh à
un moment de façon peut-être démesuré et
tout cet entourage qui les met sans
arrêt au centre de l'attention sans
arrêt à dire vous êtes les meilleurs
vous êtes les meilleurs vous êtes les
meilleurs vous avez la gloire et vous
avez tout tout arrive à vous et parfois
ce tout pour des joueurs de foot il y a
pas besoin que ce soit très compliqué
c'est pas des philosophe hein ils
réfléchissent pas à la condition humaine
c'est euh des entrées partout euh gratos
des filles qui leur disent qu'ils sont
beaux alors que quand ils é des gamins
ils ne l'étaient peut-être pas beau euh
et tout ça à ce moment-là que la passion
pour le football svapore che pe regardez
regardez un joueur on a eu il y a 24
heures l'annonce de la retraite d'Eden
Hazar un très beau jourur de foot qu'on
avait découvert nous en France
international belge à pardon à Lille à
lance pardon attention vous allez avoir
des problèmes à Lille il est champion de
France en en 2011 avec avec Lille c'est
un joueur merveilleux il part che si et
il prend sa retraite à 32 ans et à 32
ans qu'est-ce qu'il dit et finalement il
l'avait dit he un petit peu ses années
récentes il avait plus l'envie il avait
plus la passion il avait plus réellement
envie est-ce qu'on tue pas la passion à
force de transformer c'est ces joueurs
en quasiment objet de culte avec oui oui
quand les mecs vont en Arabie Saoudite
pour des en vous rendez compte ce quoi
moi j'ai jamais été un combattant de
l'argent dans le foot et du business je
suis pas DUP je sais que le business
dans le foot il a il a toujours existé
mais il prend des proportions euh il
transforme les joueurs de foot en en tel
totem que parfois je me demande s'ils
sont encore passionnés par ce qu'il font
des totems en tout cas ou des légendes
c'est le mot utilisé par Nasar alrealifi
président du parissint-germain pour
parler de de Neymar au moment de son
départ est-ce que ce terme est galvudé
selon vous ouais très souvent oui quelle
trace Neymar va laissé au
parisint-germain c'est une légende ou
pas au PSG franchement je pense que le
le point de vue sur la question sera
générationnelle peut-être que des jeunes
qui avaient 10 ans quand Neymar est
arrivé qui ont rêvé avec ce joueur le
considè comme une légende si vous me
posez la question moi qui est plus de 50
ans maintenant et qui est tout connu de
ce club pour moi il laissera une trace
quasi nulle parce
que en fait qu'est-ce qu'on attend d'un
joueur de foot est-ce que c'est
simplement des buts ou est-ce que c'est
également un échant change du partage et
un petit peu d'affect est-ce que on a
envie qu'il dise je suis content d'être
là j'aime les supporters de ce club j'ai
envie qu'on gagne ensemble jusqu'à 2020
on va dire que Neymar quand le PSG va en
finale de la Ligue des Champions il
entretient le rêve qu'il va faire vivre
aux gens quelque chose de fort derrière
malheureusement il n'a qu'alimenté la
rubrique des faits divers
ou je ne sais quoi d'ailleurs oui
c'était plus un client des boîtes de
nuit que que un bon client de
l'entraînement où il était devenu de de
moins en moins performant et même sur le
terrain il y avait ses blessures mais il
y avait beaucoup de blessures qu'
provoquait lui-même parce qu'il était
pas sérieux parce qu'il avait une
hygiène de vie déplorable donc au final
son image a été largement ternie quand
même depuis tout à l'heure on parle de
joueurs confirmés je vous donne un autre
exemple le 7 mars 2023 Bradley barco la
formma à Lyon fait une vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux dans lequelle il raconte
son attachement au club à la ville le 31
août ici au PSG comment c'est possible
de faire ça comment est-ce que vous
expliquez qu'il ait même plus cet
attachement comme c'était le cas avant à
son club formateur alors là en
revanche il faut pas faire de procès
trop rapide parce que c'est ce qui a été
fait sur je le dis en règle générale de
beaucoup de jeunes joueurs c'est arrivé
que également au PSG à une époque les
joueurs partent très vite ah oui on
adore le club et on s'en va et si on
creuse un petit peu on s'aperçoit quand
même que dans beaucoup de clubs en
France d'abord l'économie de nos clubs
repose essentiellement sur les droits
télé d'un côté et les transferts de
l'autre la mutation
quand vous avez des droits télé qui sont
en baisse et notamment avec la
catastrophe qu'il a eu entre 2018 et
2020 avec le le scandale méia pro et il
a fallu un petit peu recoller les
morceaux on a beaucoup emprunté d'argent
à l'état dans les clubs on s'est
retrouvé dans beaucoup de clubs en
grande difficultés financière c'est
l'autre pilier de l'économie des clubs
qui a prévalu à savoir la les les droits
de mutation il y a beaucoup de clubs qui
en fait forment les joueurs alors c'est
bien beau ils nous vendent l'attachement
ils nous le vendent l'affect moi je veux
pas accuser Barcola ou lukeba d'être
parti très vite de l'OL parce que je
pense qu'on a également fait en sorte de
les sortir et de leur dire on a besoin
d'argent mon grand il va falloir que tu
partes et en fait on les pousous B oui
parce que Lyon au moment du passage de
témoins entre Jean-Michel olas et
l'investisseur américain enfin la bande
d'investisseur mené par John sextor
s'est retrouvé à poil financièment parce
c'est par qu' disent eu disent qu'ils
ont voulu le garder ça c'est ce qu'ils
disent mais à un moment quand le PSG a
fait une offre à 50 millions ben c'est
une offre qu'ils ont pas pu refuser donc
après aller faire un procès au jeunes
Barcola qui oui on le sait les joueurs
évidemment ils vont pas refuser un gros
salaire et l'entourage et les agents qui
sont autour bah ils ont également des
des des bouts de gâteau à croquer dans
l'affaire parce que il touchent un
pourcentage donc oui ils ont souvent
intérêt à ce que le joueur change de
club mais attention les clubs ont
également intérêt à ça parce que
l'économie des clubs elle repose
beaucoup voir princi principalement sur
les transferts donc à l'OL bah à un
moment vu les difficultés financières
ils ont poussé tous les joueurs qui
avaient une valeur marchande ils on ont
gardé un ou deux et puis les autres il
les ont poussé dehors parce qu'il
fallait mettre de l'argent dans les
caisses je continue de de déblayer un
petit peu V votre livre d'olo à un
moment vous vous glissez un petit tacle
à did Deschamps vous dites vous dites
vous dites did Deschamp à l'époque où il
me parlait encore c'est-à-dire avant
qu'il ne supporte plus mes critiques que
s'est-il passé en il est pas vous savez
il est il est pas très original par
rapport à beaucoup de d'entraîneurs ou
de de champ du monde du foot on peut pas
critiquer les entraîneurs aujourd'hui si
mais il le ils le prennent pas bien euh
après ils disent que si c'est répété
c'est ça devient une affaire personnelle
moi j'ai absolument rien de personnel
contre des champs ou d'autres
entraîneurs euh il arrive alors puisque
comme on est une émission quotidienne si
on était une Hebdo peut-être que ça lui
semblerait un peu moins pesant mais si
on revient tous les soirs et que tous
les soirs les thèmes reviennent et que
les auditeurs appellent qu'est-ce que tu
penses du jeu de l'équipe é de France de
Deschamps oui alors peut-être qu'il a
l'impression qu'on fait une fixette euh
je sais que c'est pareil la fixette on
me la faisait sur veratti mais moi j'ai
dit tout ce que j'avais à vous dire mais
si tous les soirs il y a des gens qui
appellent et qui veulent me reparler du
sujet bah alors moi j'argumente et j'en
parle donc ça donne l'impression qu'on
se braque déchens j'ai aucun problème
avec lui il a du mal à supporter les
critiques ça oui parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui contrôle absolument tout
qui contrôle la communication sais c'est
c'est typiquement le genre de personne
qui dit moi je ne suis au courant de
rien je ne lis pas les médias ça ne
m'intéresse pas mais qui euh oui non
c'est pas c'est quelqu'un les lit pour
lui et vient lui rapporter à peu près
tout ce qu'il se dit donc après il fait
la gueule effectivement si si on le
critique et il prend et il croit qu'on
fait une affaire personnelle le dernier
en date je vous le dis avant de le dire
ce soir dans l'ffire moi j'entretenais
des rapport plutôt très courtois
récemment avec Bruno genénésio à Ren
j'apprends que récemment il a pas aimé
une ou deux de mes critiques moi je
continue
à en tout cas apprécier le personnage et
même l'entraîneur
ben non non il veut plus te parler parce
que tu l'as critiqué bon écoutez moi au
bout d'un moment qu'est-ce que voulez
que je vous dise si si on peut plus si
on peut je sais pas enfin vous êtes
connu en tout cas beaucoup sont comme ça
ouais vous êtes connu pour votre votre
Fran parler quelle quelle relation
personnelle est-ce que vous entretenez
quand je dis personnel sur le plan
professionnel évidemment mais quelle
relation est-ce que vous entretenez vous
Daniel Riolo avec les joueurs avec les
différents entraîneurs moi je cherche
pas à avoir de relation personnelle et
directe avec ni les joueurs ni ni ni les
entraîneurs les présidents évidemment ça
fait tellement longtemps qu'on est là
maintenant ils savent tous qui on est
ils savent tous ce qu'on dit
euh ce sont quand même des structures
des entreprises énormes évidemment que
elles ont des attachés de presse et des
dir comom qui font attention à ce qui se
dit et qui rapportte éventuellement les
propos que qu'on qu'on tient tous les
soirs donc eux savent absolument qui on
est ce qu'on dit nous on sait qui ils
sont et s'ils ont envie de m'appeler ils
m'appellent s'ils veulent avoir des bons
rapports avec moi ou des mauvais ou
m'engueuler ou de toute façon il ils
font très vite à trouver mon numéro de
téléphone est-ce que ça vous arrive de
vous dire là je suis allé trop loin il
va plus vouloir me parler ah non mais ça
alors ça je m'en fous complètement ça ah
ça qu' veut plus me parler ça c'est pas
un problème ça vraiment ça ça ça ça ça
n'a jamais été ça ne pourra jamais être
un souci s'il me téléphone il y a aucun
problème on se parlera on se parle je je
peux parler aux présidents aux
entraîneurs j'ai aucun souci avec aucun
mais il y a pas un président de club ou
un entraîneur à qui j'ai pas parlé
maintenant il y a eu des bons moments
des mauvais moments moi je n'ai jamais
cherché à à lier un rapport si ça se
fait tant mieux et a priori moi je n'ai
de de d'esprit malveillant à l'égard de
personne Koo Football Club histoire
secrète du foot français chez Hugo sport
édition et c'est surtout une enquête
très documentée qu'on recommande merci
beaucoup Daniel merci beaucou pour votre
présence sur notre plateau ce soir je
recommande également ce portrait que
vous a consacré ronand Planchon dans nos
page Daniel Riolo contre le règne de la
culture de l'instant un article à
retrouver bien évidemment sur Le
Figaro.fr merci encore et merci à vous
chers internautes nous